open AI are back but that doesn't mean
nothing has changed this video is about
giving you more context not only on what
happened but what it means and what else
has been going on with AI That's
arguably more important and yes it seems
Sam ultman is also back at the helm of
open AI although interestingly he said
I'm looking forward to returning to open
aai this morning seems like the terms of
that Arrangement aren't yet finalized
one thing that's definitely not back in
fashion and has arguably been lost in
the chaos is the original open AI
Charter it said it would be wise to view
any investment in open AI Global in the
spirit of a donation with the
understanding that it may be difficult
to know what role money will play in a
post AGI World furthermore the charter
takes precedence over any obligation to
generate a profit the company may never
make a profit and the company is under
no obligation to do so with a tentative
90 billion valuation I wonder how many
open AI would sign up to that Charter
again now anyway back to Las Vegas where
samman was attending the biggest party
of the weekend the Formula One race when
he was fired by the board many of the
possible reasons for that were covered
in my previous video but Ilia Sova was
asked directly to provide a reason an
hour and a half after firing samman Ilia
Sato was asked by open aai employees
will they ever find out what Sam mman
did to which he replied no this is
according to the Wall Street Journal
that reluctance apparently went so deep
that even when the new CEO EMT sheer
asked the board demanded the board to
provide concrete evidence of Sam Wan's
wrongdoing they did not do so he then
said he could not remain in the CEO role
and tried to help both sides find common
ground to get Sam wman reinstated
speaking of the outgoing CEO emit Shear
apparently when he announced an all
hands meeting fewer than a dozen people
showed up and apparently several
employees responded with middlefinger
emojis that follows on from the
executive team of openai pressing the
board for 40 minutes for specific
examples of samman's lack of cander or
honesty the board refused apparently
citing legal reasons and it seems at one
point law enforcement entities such as
the US attorney's office even got
involved at this point it seems a bit
more of the reasoning came out the board
intimated that there wasn't one incident
that led to their decision to eject
Orman but instead a consistent slow
erosion of trust over time that made
them increasingly uneasy and as I
mentioned in my previous video also
samman's mounting list of outside AI
related Ventures like creating an AI
chip which raised questions for the
board about how open AI technology or
intellectual property could be used the
board then discussed the matter with
their own legal council and after a few
hours they returned still unwilling to
provide specifics they said that samman
wasn't candid and often got his way and
they said that he'd been so deaf that
they couldn't even give a specific
example indeed the only person to go on
record about any lying actually works at
Google Deep Mind this is Jeffrey Irving
who used to work at open AI he said Sam
Orman lied to him on various occasions
was deceptive manipulative and worse to
others he said that when he lied to him
Jeffrey Irving it was about other people
to try to drive wedges but according to
the New York Times the firing might not
have even been about lying after all
apparently samman met one of the bo
members Miss Tona to discuss a paper she
had written Sam wman then wrote an email
to his colleagues reprimanding Miss Tona
for that paper saying it was dangerous
to the company particularly at a time
when the FDC was investigating open AI
Miss Tona defended her paper as an
academic paper which I have read in part
and I'll get to in a moment and said it
was analyzing the challenges that the
public faces when trying to understand
the intentions of the companies
developing AI but Sam mman disagreed and
said I did not feel we're on the same
page on the damage of all of this any
amount of criticism from a board member
carries a lot of weight Honestly though
before today I hadn't heard of the paper
or heard anyone discussing it so what
does the paper say well on page 30 we
have this first heaps of praise for open
AI for publishing a system card
outlining the risks of GPT 4 after that
praise though they do say that the
release of chat GPT 4 months earlier
overshadowed the import of that system
card the paper then describes how chat
gbt's release sparked a sense of urgency
inside Major tech companies one thing
the paper did do though was praise
anthropic the Rival to open AI it
singled out their different approach of
delaying model releases until the
industry had caught up it quoted how
anthropics chatbot clawed had been
deliberately delayed in order to avoid
advancing the rate of AI capabilities
progress now many people won't remember
this but this was actually cited in the
GPT 4 technical report that report
released in March warned of acceleration
as a risk to be addressed and advisers
that they employed told them to delay
gp4 by a further 6 months and be a bit
quieter in the communication strategy
around deployment tona's paper did then
describe the quote frantic Corner
cutting that the release of chat GPT
appeared to Spur but honestly it's a
fairly nuanced report and then critiques
anthropics approach saying it's ignored
by many the report says by burying the
explanation of claude's delayed release
in the middle of a long detailed
document posted to the company's website
anthropic appears to have ensured that
this signal of its intentions around AI
safety has gone largely unno and before
you think that she must be alone at open
aai in critiquing the release of chat PT
samman himself listed it as a possible
future regret we're definitely going to
have some huge regrets um 20 years from
now I hope what we can say is that we
did far far far more good than bad and I
think we will I think that's true but
the downside here is is pretty big and I
think we feel that weight every day
honestly I think if we're going to
regret something it may be that we
already pushed the button like we've
already launched this revolution it's
somewhat out of our hands I think it's
going to be great but like this is going
to happen now right like this we've
we're out of the the world is like out
of the gates I I guess the thing that I
lose the most sleepover is that we
already have done something really bad I
don't think we have but the hypothetical
that
we by launching chat GPT into the world
shot the industry out of a rail gun and
we now don't get to have much impact
anymore and there's going to be an
acceleration towards making these
systems which again I think will be used
for tremendous good and and I think
we're going to address all the problems
but maybe there's something in there
that was really really hard and
complicated in a way we didn't
understand and you know we've now
already kicked this off but if that's
more of the context what about what
actually happened on the weekend well
samman's house became apparently a war
room filled with open AI employees
including miror mirati the interim CEO
they began to use X or Twitter in a
coordinated fashion for their campaign
this was also the time of the open
letter to the board of directors from
the employees of open AI by my last
count it was signed by
747 out of the 770 open AI employees it
described how the board stated that
allowing the company to be destroyed
wouldn't necessarily be inconsistent
with the mission of creating safe and
beneficial AGI the employees then
threatened to resign from open aai and
All Join Microsoft notice how the threat
is to take this step imminently unless
all current board members resign as as
of now though it seems like samman has
agreed not to return to the board while
Adam dangelo will stay furthermore
samman has agreed to allow an
investigation into his Affairs before
the firing remember that Adam D'Angelo
the CEO of Kora and one of the people
who voted to remove samman was described
by samman in a blog post from a few
years ago as one of the few names that
people consistently mention when
discussing the smartest CEOs in Silicon
Valley and samman said he has a very
long-term Focus which has become a rare
commodity in tech companies these days I
wonder if he would reaffirm that about
Adam dangelo now but back to Microsoft
who had not only announced the arrival
of samman but even gotten a floor of
their office in San Francisco ready with
laptops and clusters of gpus SAA Adela
the CEO of Microsoft even said that Sam
wman and Greg Brockman were in the
process of joining Microsoft so how are
you envisioning this role with the sort
of you know Advanced AI team that Sam
and Greg would be joining and leading
can you explain that and are they
actually Microsoft employees right now
like who do they work
for yeah so they're all in the process
of joining and yes I mean the thing is
look you know we have a ton of AI
expertise in this company and Kevin
Scott the CTO of Microsoft said this we
have seen your petition and appreciate
your desire potentially to join samman
at Microsoft new research lab speaking
as if samman had already joined know
that if needed you have a role at
Microsoft that matches your compensation
and advances our Collective Mission so
what does Microsoft now make of open AI
not joining them and instead staying
independent sassin Adela said this we
are encouraged by the changes to the
open aai board we believe this is an
essential first step on a path through a
more stable well-informed and effective
governance Sam Greg and I have talked
and agreed they have a key role to play
notice is not really defined with the
open AI leadership team in ensuring open
AI continues to thrive and build on its
Mission but a more revealing quote from
nadela came last night in an interview
with Cara swisser we're never going to
get back into a situation where we're
surprised like this again and Bloomberg
are reporting that the final reworked
open AI board will have up to nine new
directors with Microsoft getting
possibly one or more seats one of the
new board members will be Larry Summers
and I'll get to him in a moment but
first there's something that slipped out
during the chaos that I want to pick up
on at one point during the weekend open
ai's board approached anthropic about a
merger and I'll give myself a little bit
of credit for predicting that in one of
my previous videos anyway apparently
that was quickly turned down by Dario
amade the CEO of anthropic I'm going to
get two other AI news in a second but
first a quick look at the views of Larry
Summers on AI he views language models
as a major wakeup call for the white
collar worker I think it's coming for uh
the cognitive class chety PT is going to
replace what doctors do hearing symptoms
and making diagnosis before it changes
what nurses do before we leave this open
AI Saga there's one more thing I wanted
to point out I'm going all the way back
to that open AI Charter that I
introduced in the beginning and the
fifth Clause says this the determines
when we've reached AGI Again by AGI we
mean a highly autonomous system that
outperforms humans at most economically
valuable work when the board determines
that we have attained AGI such a system
is excluded from IP licenses and other
commercial terms with Microsoft but
unless open Ai and the board want this
entire Saga to repeat again I think they
really need to better Define AGI what
does highly autonomous mean more
importantly what does outperforming
humans at most economically valuable
work even mean the AI and broader
technology we have today if we
transported it back 200 years in the
past would be able to outperform most
humans at most economically valuable
work obviously what happened is that
humans reacted to that and changed how
they work so this debate could arise
again in the not too distant future open
AI talk about aligning superintelligence
within 4 years but if the board declares
AGI Microsoft might be able to say well
we haven't yet reached post- labor
economics people are still contributing
in economically valuable ways as carers
or as entertainers or YouTube hosts or
whatever else happens I do feel the
world needs to come up with a much more
rigorous definition of AGI so yes I
agree with Mustafa sullon that it has
been an utterly insane weekend but it's
time at last to move on to other AI news
because apparently inflection AI have
finished training the second best large
language model in the World some will be
surprised that it's only the second best
llm still behind GPT 4 he does though
say that we're scaling much further and
they are more than capable of doing so
to train inflection 2 the startup used
only 5,000 Nvidia h100 gpus when they
have a supercomputer with 22,000 h100s
nevertheless you can see the
improvements from inflection one to
inflection 2 beating Palm 2 which now
Powers Bard it also apparently beats
xai's grock 1 and anthropic Claude 2.0
model and anthropic who we've already
mentioned multiple times today have
introduced Claude 2.1 notice the number
there not going for the dramatic 2.5 or
three just 2.1 that's kind of an
admission that this is quite a small
iterative update essentially they've
scaled up their context window to
200,000 tokens that's maybe 150,000
words if this this was open AI this
would probably be an entire event but
it's just a blog post apparently they've
made it so that claw 2.1 is much more
honest about when it doesn't know the
answer to a hard question instead of
just blurting out a hallucination it
will be much more likely just to say I
don't know the number of errors that
Claude 2.1 makes about questions
relating to the middle beginning and end
of long documents seems to have gone
down but that definitely doesn't mean
that it's reliable for questions
particularly if those questions pertain
to the middle of the document notice if
the fact that you're trying to find
comes right at the beginning this top
row or right at the end of a document it
will do well but especially when you're
dealing with those really long books or
multiple documents up to 200,000 tokens
the errors for the middle can be quite
dramatic compare that to a shorter say
15,000 Word document this column is all
green even for the middle of that
document but all of what I've covered in
this video PS in comparison to AI
advances like this one this was
published in nature on Monday AI
detection of a certain type of
pancreatic cancer pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma apparently the most
deadly solid malignancy has now
overtaken mean radiologist performance
translated AI doing better than human
doctor performance and by fair margin
34% in sensitivity and 6% in specificity
sensitivity is about not missing cancers
that are there and specificity is about
not saying there is a cancer when there
isn't but in both cases it's
outperforming mean radiologist
performance this is an AI advance that
could genuinely save thousands of lives
and on that crazy optimistic note I want
to end the video thank you as always for
watching to the end I promise to get to
more non-open ai ai news in the future
and have a wonderful day